[MUSIC]
What are some of the most common myths
about the Stanford application process?
>> I think the myth that I
hear most frequently is that
members of the Admissions Committee at
Stanford have some magic checklist that
each applicant must fulfill in order
to be admitted to our program.
I've heard things like,
I have to have a GMAT score over 700, or
I need to work in a particular
industry to be admitted, or
even come from a particular type
of educational institution.
And really,
nothing could be farther from the truth.
If you think about the last few classes
that we've admitted, we have students from
over 60 different countries, we have
students from a 160 different educational
institutions, and we have students coming
from, I think, on average over 300
different work environments before
they come, different companies.
And there's only 400
students in [LAUGH] a class.
So you can see, in reality, we're
admitting humans for what they've done and
who they are.
We're not admitting people just because
they went to a certain institution or
worked in a certain industry.
In fact, I was just,
I think it was a few weekends ago,
we were at Admitted Students Weekend,
which I know you've been to,
Admit Weekend, and
there was two students I was talking to.
And both of them said,
they almost didn't apply to Stanford.
Like, I came this close to not applying.
I'm like, why?
One said he was in chatroom and somebody
told him that Stanford will never admit
you because the institution, [COUGH]
because the university that you went to.
And he went to a state
school in the Midwest.
And then another student said
the same thing had happened to her.
And one of her peers
from work had told her,
they were talking about where they
wanted to apply, that with her GPA and
test scores,
she'd never get into Stanford.
So luckily for us, both of these students
decided that, for themselves, whether or
not they should apply, and
are now going to be entering this fall.
So we're really excited about that.
I think what's most important
to me is to tell you,
do not underestimate your own potential.
There's no perfect applicant.
There's no checklist that we're looking
at of attributes that we require.
Decide for yourself whether
you're worth the investment to
go through the application process.
And what I know from talking to many, many
applicants in the past, that you spending
the time to know whats important to you,
what you value, what you're aspirations
are, and then what you've really done and
the accomplishments you've had,
those are going to be critical to you at
this point in time no matter what you do.
So we're genuinely excited
to learn about you.
To learn about how you've actually
had impact on your teams and
your organizations and
your communities and what you care about.
So if you have a story to tell us,
you know that we're here and
genuinely ready and excited to read it.